jeopardy Morgan I play Carol I'm Cooper
Anders I am Megan I'm not a looker
I'm Darrell I'm Eleanor missoura I'm
Magno I'm Norman Reedus
I play Glenn okay we are about to take
ace BuzzFeed quiz of how we would
survive the apocalypse first alright
what would you miss the most during an
apocalypse your cell phone a hot shower
your bed my pet Netflix your favorite
foods I'm gonna miss all these things I
mean food a world of eating dirt and
worms --is I'm gonna go with bed yeah me
too I'm with you I'm a Cape foods for me
my pet okay
did not eat it I pick a place to set up
your camp my hospital a mom prison farm
a school grocery store farm I'm going
with mold I'll have everything you need
including beds food yeah well I'm gonna
go with your phone because I could just
live forever grow your own stuff got
your pets a bed we'd be so cool a
hospital for me though drugs lots you
just look into the drug Angela I just
need to ask for this taste of my mom
although the end of the grocery store is
not a bad place to be if it's got lots
of like Twinkies it is gonna be gone ya
know the fun wins I'm not sharing my bed
from the previous question you come
across an abandoned store what items do
you grab rescue flares first-aid kit
canned food water filter ammunition a
map of the area water filter yeah
did you have a gun he's happy right
the dad doesn't say we done they have a
part of all bullets in the gun take my
gun
canned food what if it's all onions you
know right word all right
I went with water filter where we all
get sure what's the walking dead or is
your favorite Carol Ann Darrow negan and
Lucille Michonne and Judith Rosita
Eugene Ezekiel Jerry and Connie and
Kelly Carolyn don't know I'm invested
Ilyn Jerry I'm with you I don't know why
either it's just me to see my dress
that's why I'm going my shrine and
Judith that's so cute
the obvious right answer is negan
Lucille but I'm gonna say Rosita and
Eugene because I missed them and they
should be here with us to Blair if you
back any Walking Dead character who
would it be
Rick Sasha Glenn
tarah Carl or Beth I'm bringing
backgrounds I'm bringing back to the
Grimes as well I'm bringing that Glenn
because Rick talked to a - I like Glenn
I'm bringing him back - I'm gonna bring
back Sasha because they want to be here
how would your BFFs describe you
ambitious adventurous sarcastic -
generous caring I'm a mix between
sarcastic and caring elements are caring
I'm just gonna go with the Karen I'm
sarcastic in generous I don't care yeah
you are you're generous doesn't well
thanks for caring
yeah so basically what we got it as
we're all a bunch of liars
finally pick an iconic item from the
Walking Dead universe
Carl's hat Glenn's pocket watch Darryl's
vest Carol's cookies Michonne's katana
or Rick's gun katana I'm gonna go with
the watch just because of how many hands
it's passed through from Hershel of gun
- I'm taking Darryl's vest I'm taking
Carl's hat I'm taking Carol's cookies
hmm I take the gun if there was bullets
around you have three of those in this
Smithsonian so you're saying that that'd
be hard to get back well they're all
like things that's true yeah the cookies
aren't gonna be there great here's your
result
you got uh-oh you were eaten by a walker
we're sorry to break it to you but you
can't survive The Walking Dead
you died protecting the people you care
about which is the bravest thing anyone
in this world could do you got
Congrats you'd survive you 6x 6x so
actually successfully it's about the
walking dead while you watch some of
your closest friends follow you stay
strong we suggest you celebrate by
eating someone probably save you guys
yeah his wife
[Music]